in the lobby of Ramsey solutions however
better news is Tyler and Bri hey guys
how are you pretty good yourself
welcome welcome where do you guys live
we're from Iowa central Iowa cool part
Marshalltown
yeah good and that's the Des Moines area
right about an hour yep okay cool
welcome to Nashville and you're here all
the way dead free scream yeah how much
have you paid off it's technically we
paid off our house which was fifty two
thousand dollars I'm 21 oh my gosh I'm
24 25 years old fifty two thousand bucks
yeah wow that's amazing what's the house
worth we'd say now we've done some
renovations probably between 50 and 70
but in central Iowa that's probably not
the same as Nashville so how many square
feet is this house about 1200 square
foot okay very nice very nice good
starter home for a young couple and and
we also paid for college along the way
as well we cash flowed that that's how
much was that that was roughly twenty
thousand dollars over what period of
time did you do these two things well we
got married three years ago and we were
I was kind of already on the plan
started the emergency fund I had just
finished college so I cash flowed my way
through college and then we still had
two more years so so really the it's
been about three years from time you've
got married you've been beating on the
house and getting Brie through school
yeah very good and your range of income
during that three years and we started
probably 65 and did probably around 105
now Wow what do you guys do for a living
well for when I first started I was
working like a minimum wage job just
like I was a receptionist and now I have
my own small business and I've been
doing really well I'm a photographer
I'm an insurance underwriter
yeah good way to go you guys
so how in the world do you get this
smart at 21 to 24 years old we listen to
you Dave take all the credit not really
I'm so impressed we had to be like
parents influence or something so I had
started school I got some student debt I
was like 5,000 I heard this dude on the
radio I'm like I wanted to do talking
about and so finally eventually came
around to me I got smarter paid that off
and we kind of just said we're gonna do
this you know we both grew up I grew up
in a trailer so you know you see what
the good the bad and you learn a lot you
know and I was like that's not how my
life is gonna go Ryan and so when we got
married we're like let's just do this
three years we'll be done might not be
the best house in the world but we're
free not paid for house I'll tell you
that that's right and like you man I'll
tell you and it's gonna go up in value
and you've already done some renovations
to it very cool so Bri this guy is
listening this crazy man on the radio
and you look up decide he wants to start
talking to you about getting married and
all this and you're like what did you
say well I was 18 when I got married to
him right out of high school so and I
went we knew we wanted to get married
and we've been saving when we were in
high school because we'd been dating for
about five years before we shall hood
sweetheart yeah so yeah I knew that we
wanted to get married and I wanted to
get on board and be able to do that so
that's what we did I gonna admit I
probably curse your name a few times how
bad yeah we did it
wow you're so impressive very cool so
what's your degree in Bri marketing in
HR
Wow good for you thank you you guys cash
flow that through get married straight
out of high school and then you work
your butt off and you pay for college
and you pay off your house we ate a lot
of pork chops I can't eat any more
important everyone should have a food
that's they're broke people food that
they never want to eat again monster so
disgusting now I just
smell is awful mine's tuna fish Sharon
just make me tuna fish sandwiches and I
would go to work broke and they'd be in
the refrigerator and they get soggy
during the day you know like soggy tuna
fish sandwiches gross gross gross
I smell tuna fish my net worth goes down
now I hate it
Hey yeah pork chops will always be that
way for you that's okay you got out
broke people food that's good I like it
you're not broke people anymore you're
on your way to being multi
multi-millionaire oh my goodness between
the two of you I mean 24 and 21
household income of a hundred and five
not a payment in the world and I've
learned to work together and I mean fell
in love in the eighth grade my gosh Wow
my dad was a fan of that one was he a
fan by the time you got out of school
yes okay and is he a fan now yes he's
half Ivan going yeah my son laws the
stud this is awesome very good very cool
so did you have people cheering you on
you know we've been pretty quiet about
this and some people that are listening
to this might not know that we were even
on it we we don't share a ton about kind
of our finances but we've been on the
plan people close to us know we've been
on the plan and I mean I guess we've got
a lot of motivation from this show we've
gotten to some live events but whatever
Wow which live event did you go to we
went out to Denver a couple years ago
our conference yeah yeah oh wow the
whole smart yeah that was a good one
yeah that's cool that was fun yeah you
come out of there like on the rocky
steroids me yeah yeah that's more
conferences are amazing and at your age
going in I mean your marriage and and
everything wow wow wow you are awesome
your future's so bright it's
unbelievable so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is I
would say it was also cool because yeah
we've got this goal done right we've
we've done this plan mm-hmm but more
importantly it's given us something when
we first started marriage you know we're
young we don't know a lot about marriage
and it gave us something to work towards
together and we were always on board
obviously we had disagreements about how
to do certain things but he got us on
the same page and it helped us work
together as a team and
do what we considered a pretty big goal
so absolutely what would you say I don't
know I just think working together is
really important and just communication
was what we founded our relationship on
early on and that's I think what really
helped us get out of debt is talking to
each other and communicating when we
both weren't on board with something or
if we decided that that we needed to up
our spending money which is something
that I argued for a lot but yeah he was
at first he was a little I was a little
extreme he's a little strict then you
know we just kept communicating and
making sure we were on the same page so
we could work toward goal the goals
together wow you guys have so much
future ahead of you this is amazing and
you got such a runway man this is great
a well done very well I'm so proud of
you well done very well done we got a
copy of Chris Hogan's retire inspired
book for you that is the next chapter in
your story for sure millionaire and
outrageously generous as you go along
you guys let us know how you're doing I
want to hear the rest of this story as
it unfolds you started so young it's
just going to be it's going to be ten
years from now where you're going to be
doing me unbelievable alright it's Tyler
and Bri 21 and 24 their house and
everything is paid for household income
of 105 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream ready one two three
I love it Wow this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]